Десантний корабель ВМС США "Форт МакГенрі".
На містку обговорюють останні деталі. З камерою туди не пускають - підвищена секретність.
"Форт МакГенрі" в поході ось уже кілька місяців. У січні, приміром, заходив у Чорне море.
Нині ось у Балтійському.
Екіпаж корабля налічує близько 400 матросів та офіцерів.
Крім того, на борт можна взяти ще 400 морських піхотинців.
Плюс купа всілякої техніки: джипи, вантажІвки, транспортні катери і десантні машини-амфібії.
Наші морські піхотинці довго тренувалися.
Ми проводимо навчання по цілому світу і завжди чекаємо цих навчань.
Висадка десанту очікується, зокрема, на узбережжі Естонії та Латвії.
На запитання, чому саме там, організатори навчань пояснили,
що це стандартна процедура -
країни-учасниці пропонують свої полігони, потім ухвалюється рішення.
У нас буде можливість провести десантну операцію, під час якої випробуємо техніку.
Також проведемо навчання в небі. Так що буде чудова можливість попрацювати з іншими країнами,
а також потренуватися самим.
Морські маневри, що стартували в Німеччині, найбільші за останні 30 років:
задіяно 18 країн, понад 8 з половиною тисяч осіб,
50 кораблів і 2 субмарини, відпрацювання дій на морі і на суші.
За даними представників "Балтопс", військові навчання не спрямовані проти третіх країн.
Але до російської Калінінградської області від місця проведення навчань зовсім близько.
І в російському міністерстві оборони вже заявили, що стежать за маневрами.
Другий флот США, який ще називали "флотом холодної війни", був відновлений минулого року -
у зв'язку зі збільшенням напруги між Росією і НАТО.
Навчання на Балтиці - свого роду прем'єра для командування 2-го флоту.
Керує навчаннями віце-адмірал Ендрю Льюіс, який очолює 2-ий флот США.
В ексклюзивному інтерв'ю DW він наголосив:
Росія - балтійська країна. Але Балтійське море і небо над ним - міжнародний простір.
У нас у всіх є право його використовувати, виходячи з міжнародного права.
Захід останнім часом не раз звинувачував Москву в порушенні морського права,
зокрема і в Керченській протоці.
На тлі мінливої ​​ситуації з глобальною безпекою Льюіс називає Росію конкурентом.
Так само як і Китай, який має проблеми в Південно-Китайському морі.
За словами віце-адмірала, 2-ий флот також відтворений для того,
щоб більш ефективно діяти не тільки в Атлантиці, а й в Арктиці.
Ми повинні бути готові до того, щоб діяти в Арктиці в майбутньому,
професійно, відповідно до морського права.
Тому що Арктика є міжнародним простором.
Адже США - арктична держава, Росія, Норвегія та інші.
Ми повинні бути в змозі працювати там і підтримувати стабільну зону.
Після інтерв'ю адмірал Льюіс вирушив назад на командно-штабний корабель
"Маунт Уїтні", аби стежити за навчаннями.
Маневри Baltops 2019 триватимуть до 21 червня.